seguir el camino hacia el norte o
resignarse es El dilema que enfrentan
miles de venezolanos después del anuncio
de Estados Unidos de que aquellos que
crucen serán devueltos a México
Precisamente en el sur de México se está
formando una caravana de miles de
migrantes pretenden llegar juntos hasta
Estados Unidos no se rinden solamente
queremos llegar hasta el punto que nos
corresponde este poco de gente aquí no
se va a frenar sino hasta llegar hasta
la meta para cumplir todo un sueño que
queremos cumplir todo aquello que
podemos caminando y así sea caminar todo
santo día y noche hasta llegar al final
eso lo vamos a cumplir
pero el estado de ánimo no es igual para
todos así están las calles de Ciudad
Juárez fronteriza con el estado de Texas
los refugios están saturados y muchos
deben dormir en la calle
tapándonos del frío No porque yo quiera
mientras en la capital algunos se
resignan en su objetivo las colas crecen
frente a la comisión mexicana de
asistencia refugiados no logramos llegar
allá pero ya con eso con ese cambio que
ellos hicieron ya ya que parece que no
vamos a quedar acá México no es una
opción para los venezolanos pero Eduardo
Rodríguez recomienda sus compatriotas
quedarse si se tiene que quedar aquí en
México que hay bastante oportunidad que
se queden en México la verdad que en
México tiene muchísimas oportunidades de
trabajo muchísima oportunidad de vida
Estados Unidos solo permitirá la entrada
por aire de 24.000 venezolanos Mientras
que el departamento de seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos cifra en
80.000 los migrantes que cruzaron de
forma irregular en el último año por lo
que ante la nueva ley los venezolanos
están ante una encrucijada